my name is Gary housing with
international justice mission and my
Davos moment occurred last night when I
found myself seated next to my mom who
is my new hero in the world that's the
Prime Minister of Georgia this is a
leader who effectively crushed
corruption in this country in eight
years time in 2003 Georgia was one of
the worst countries for watching the
world you know it ranked as one of the
best countries it is even and the United
States in terms of great year he did
this suggests very very good leadership
that came from a popular mandate and now
for instance the police which was one of
the most corrupt maintenance and in all
of society that has added a trust rating
of ninety-one percent throughout that
country they took all the steps that
they needed to all made all the
difficult decisions to actually move
from corruption to integrity and
transparency he had the courage for
instance to fire 18,000 traffic police
officers in one day and he said that the
traffic improved in his country in that
day but also as to replace them with
police officers who were well-trained
and were actually serving the public it
used to be that a police officer was
paid ten dollars a month but he had to
pay a bribe of ten thousand dollars to
even get that job and the whole
presumption was of course that you make
your money not for me salary but from
the bribe well they brought a whole new
day to Georgia and in a world with its
learning to see how you can talk with a
problem of corruption I met my hero and
I heard the greatest story last night on
how to get besdoung and that happened
for me here at Davos